Doc, Brian, congratulations.
You fellas are in the last
round of this competition,
and now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon set from history,
the classic tomahawk and Bowie.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck.
DOC: Today, I have to build
a tomahawk and a Bowie knife.
I have never made a
tomahawk, but I'm super
excited about doing that today.
I'm planning on first
forging the Bowie
and then start working on
the billet for the tomahawk.
That went very well.
Didn't have any major boo-boos.
She is done for the night.
Now it's time to start
working on the hawk.
This is a wrought-iron leg vise.
I am going to salvage
some of the wrought iron
and make the body of
the tomahawk with that.
Traditionally, hawks were
made with wrought iron
with a bit welded into it.
So I am going to do a
traditional tomahawk
with a bit insert.
Knife and a half a hawk.
That's not too terrible.
BRIAN: It's time now to
start on this tomahawk.
Drifting the eye, this is
uncharted territory, so we're
going to see where we go.
I wanted this ax head to be nice
and tough, ready for the tests
they're going to do.
So right now, I've got
my link from the shaft
to the cutting edge.
So at the end of day two,
I've got a knife that
is ready to have the
handles on, and I've
got a tomahawk head ready
to be heat treated tomorrow.
DOC: The morning of day
two, and I am stoked.
Big plans for today.
With the tomahawk, I want
to go ahead and get the eye
drifted, get the bit welded in.
I have to get these
weapons heat treated today.
I think it's
looking pretty good.
Right now, I am going
to split the front of it
and get a bit in it.
Put the cold bit
into the hot head.
Get everything
fluxed up and start
bringing it up to welding heat.
With the tomahawk, as
I'm drawing it out,
I noticed the dark
line, and it opens up.
I'm going to get it hot and
hit it and see if that weld's
going to hold or not.
If this doesn't work,
then it'll be a whole lot
of work today for nothing.
It didn't weld to
the back of the bit.
So--
It's done.
I've got to start
over from scratch.
So I take a piece of leaf
spring, then start moving it.
I am not happy today.
I still have a lot
of stuff to get done.
I don't know if I'm going
to be able to pull it off.
BRIAN: Going into day three,
got my Bowie knife completed,
handle ready to put together,
and tomahawk ready for heat
treat.
I do my final test,
and she's a-skating.
I love that sound.
Got a pretty substantial
amount of black walnut here.
I have got to do
a lot of grinding.
And I decide to
try to test fit it,
and it just comes
right off of the end.
I ground out too
much off the handle.
Got a little grinder happy.
If I can't get this
fit up properly,
that could be a potential
place for failure.
The easiest thing
that I can do is
pop a little weld
inside this eye
and see if I can make this work.
I get the tomahawk head slid up.
All that's left to do now is put
a few finishing touches on it.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
We're going to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do.
I'm going to take your weapons
and deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Doc, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, I am.
[music playing]
All right, Doc, let's
talk about your set here.
I love the feel of your Bowie,
and I can thrust and slash
without any issues at all.
Now your tomahawk,
good weight to it.
You can definitely
feel an impact,
and it definitely slashes nicely
when you're trying to cut.
There is a little
rattle, but it's
not enough to where you're going
to feel like it's coming off.
Overall, sir, your tomahawk
and Bowie will kill.
Nice.
All right, Brian,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
All right.
[music playing]
All right, Brian,
talk about your Bowie.
The size is right
on your handle.
The scale you have there
really fits in my hand.
When you cut through
that and you stab,
you can really feel
a deep wound channel.
Now your tomahawk.
It's so light I'm like,
am I picking up a stick?
But when you strike this
skull, it dug in very deep.
And overall, it will kill.
Yeah.
All right, gentlemen,
time for the strength test,
our throw and chop.
I'll be using your
Bowies and tomahawks
to throw into our
target wall and then
chop into our fence rail.
Now, this test isn't about what
your tomahawks do to the fence
rail or the target.
It's about what those targets
can do to your tomahawks
and/or Bowies, all right?
All right, Doc, you're up first.
You ready?
Definitely.
[music playing]
All right, so, Doc, right off,
you got a good weight to it.
There's enough weight there
to get some good momentum
in the throw.
This is a friction fit, correct?
Correct.
It's a very traditional
way to do this.
I'm not surprised
that with throwing it,
it's come a little bit loose.
As far as your Bowie goes,
the grinds are beautiful.
You've got that hollow, and
then your clip point meets it,
and that gives a lot of
support for that tip.
So well done.
Thank you.
All right, Brian, you're up.
Are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Brian, right off,
that throws beautifully.
There's a bit of a twisted
warp to the handle.
So when I grab it and
index off the feel,
the head's just a
little bit to one side.
As far as your Bowie goes,
I like the look of this.
Everything's still
tight as a set.
I think they go
really well together.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness test,
the sandman slice.
Now, to test the
sharpness of your weapons,
I will take your weapon
and cut up the sandman.
What's up, Doc?
You ready for this?
Definitely.
[music playing]
All right, Doc, as you
can see with a compression
fit, a couple of times
that thing loosened up.
It shouldn't be that loose
to where it comes and moves
around when you're
moving with the weapon,
especially when you're
doing some kind of attack
or a test with it.
This is a nice stabber
with your Bowie here.
And the chops, as you can
see, are also deep chops.
But then again with
this kind of thing
when you're chopping
through, it just loosens up,
and that's an issue.
Overall, it will cut.
All right, Brian,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Brian, let's talk about
your weapons right here.
The Bowie's edge
slices and dices.
You can hook nicely
with your tomahawk,
and your tomahawk digs in
when you're cutting also.
And overall, your
weapons, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, your
weapons have been tested.
The judges have
evaluated your work.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" champion is Brian.
Congratulations.
Unfortunately, Doc, at
this time I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
If I could have done
something differently,
I would have probably
figured a way
to place the pin
somewhere to keep the head
from sliding back down.
I came here to have fun.
That was my number-one goal,
and this has been a blast.
Probably been one of the
best experiences in my life.
Brian, you are the new
"Forged in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations, my friend.
Come on over here
and shake our hands.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
Good job, man.
BRIAN: It's amazing.
I've learned a lot.
I learned that you don't
quit when you're behind.
Plans I have for that
$10,000 is taking my wife
on the honeymoon we didn't get.
We'll be 10 years
married, so I'm going
to treat her to something nice.
[music playing]